lens flares are an issue in 360. so
here's a classic lens flare
ufo is all bright all the lines are
straight because it's just it's a visual
artifact within a lens so it's just like
light beams out in different directions
but now look at this here because you
put it on an equirectangular map when
you unwrap it all those lines get
curved this is not how lens flares work
this is like some crazy octopus made out
of light so the trick is to put it in
there in such a way that the lines don't
get distorted when you understood it we
are building costume racks for
the upstairs loft it's a complete mess
we need to get that straightened out so
we don't ruin all of our valuable
costumes
post day one i've got my buddies rick
and tony working on putting this all
together and so far
they've done a fantastic job we're doing
seven foot high railing that's gonna go
all the way down shelves for bins
different types of items yeah we can
like group together and then i'll put
additional racks in front of them
[Music]
literally just took that entire
equirectangular image and split it into
six different faces basically it's
called a cube map instead of a sphere
everything gets compressed into a cube
and then you can just take each of those
faces and unfold them so i i could do
this if i make the flare small enough to
fit within one of those cube faces
that will work it's a hack but it'll
work i want the flare to be really big
and go from like here to here
which requires
integrating it somehow this video has to
be done by the end of the day and it's
already 5 30. yeah how's it going uh oh
we are mostly on track
nice mostly uh i hear trains run mostly
on tracks so you're done in like two
hours or so
no
no today's not payday for you no
oh that's why because it's skybox
interesting yeah that's what what i've
got going right now you had an after
effects camera that has a 360 degree
field of view
they finished and it looks great
[Music]
hey
so we've got our four foot high
half racks here for jeans and t-shirts
then we've got our full length eight
foot jacket bench on top as well for
bins over here we've got a two by eight
layout table so when you're pulling
things off racks you can lay it out here
and then underneath is storage for bins
and a railing so
you don't fall over
no you can't i tested this already i
forgot yeah i think the solution is a
circle with a feather mask that's just
about the size of this edge real solid
solution to me solid solution but
solutions are liquid
hey i'm going to join in on this what's
going on you can't get your 3d 360 stuff
to work you are the person who did this
before how did you do it and make it
work whoa
i don't know what have you been doing
we've got this costume rack completed
and now we're trying to figure out how
to reorganize it all the biggest
question in my mind is
even if we reorganized all this stuff
and put it up there
like i don't even know if we'll have
room there's no organization to it
whatsoever i think you just need to do
that process once more something yes
solutions
two more hours till
it needs to be done
somehow